uh let's see i broke my  elbow i broke my pelvis i broke my femur  two months ago  um still coming back from that one  separated my shoulder  two knees region on this knee one knee  surgery on this knee one was  both cartilage um  other than that my ankles just are just  loose yeah like i never broke them but  they roll really easily it's almost like  i would have benefited from breaking  them yeah at the time  and rolling ankles just  uh  yeah that's why i gave up that is  literally why i gave up street skating  because of yeah yeah yeah i rolled my  ankle super bad on two or one time i had  it all taped up  we went  just shooting like messing around  downtown in between  our uh tour stops yeah went down these  little three stairs rolled the other one  just as bad  and then i'm on tour with both my ankles  taped up so they can't move and i was  like this is a sign that i don't i  should not street skate anymore